the truth about women is they are always
going to be a weakness for a man I ask
you Richard you can tell me have you
ever seen a dude like completely
obsessed over a chick and simping over
and telling the world how great she is
who doesn't end up regretting it like
Kim left Kanye Tom Brady's [ __ ] laugh
who's that rapper who just got killed PB
rock or some [ __ ] he was with a girl in
a restaurant dinner in a restaurant and
they blasted him outside yeah well she's
probably [ __ ] someone else by now and
you're dead women will get you killed
fast and you're right women don't like
the idea of being protected and censored
in that way sometimes it's difficult to
sit down with a woman and just explain
to her I have enemies and people don't
like me oh yeah but you're strong listen
there are people that are all group
there are gangs armed who don't like me
like you can't just be sitting there
[ __ ] saying where we are put your
phone away so yeah it's annoying but
it's just a harsh reality of life